[Music]
I want to tell you guys a little bit
about the Doppler shift you might know a
little bit about it but I want to sort
of Flesh it out some more that'd be good
for me you've surely heard of it this is
the shift
in the frequency of sound
between when an object is approaching
you versus when it's receding we know it
intuitively that's the fun part about it
yeah even if you didn't know there was a
word for it we know it because for
example you've if you're if you're on
the side of a freeway or even at a race
track there's the sound of the car as it
approaches you and it goes
and that's different from the sound it
makes as it recedes from you it goes
and you put them together you got no
yeah okay
I I know it
because there is a meme of you given a
talk and doing that and as soon as you
do it they show a hurricane and a sign
that knocks a woman
today and yesterday what okay okay I've
seen I've seen one of those memes where
somebody loads a fish into a cannon and
then fish and then it goes no and then
it lands in a fish shop somewhere yeah
so okay I've only I didn't know that
they but the one to do is hilarious
having never grown up near a NASCAR
track or a racetrack of any kind I would
know that what you've just described
from aircraft that would fly overhead
[Applause]
easier at like at an airport you'd get
more of that yes yeah okay yeah so so
the point is if I recited that Doppler
effect sound differently you would say
what's wrong with you right if I went
[Music]
no you know intuitively that that's
wrong that's true or no no it's no
stop laughing at my doctor
it just sounds like a car going by with
a cat hanging out the window
that's having the time of its life I
think Chuck is jealous because he wishes
he could do the Doppler shift so okay so
Neil so here's my point here's my point
so it turns out
that the frequency of sound that is
actually being made
is accurate only when the car is
directly in front of you
passing by okay
so when it's coming towards you the
sound waves are compressed
which puts more crests and troughs by
you per second more Wiggles and if it's
more per second that's a higher
frequency that's what frequency is how
many crystals per second yeah so higher
frequency sound another word for that is
a higher pitch okay as it's receding
from you each next sound wave is now
stretched
from the previous one and so that's a
lower pitch but if it's right passing in
front of you it's neither coming towards
you nor away so the only truly accurate
signal you can receive from the car is
right when it passes in front of you
just just a point of information there
so what do we do with electric cars okay
it turns out that not all of the sounds
you hear is the engine no right okay and
in fact depending on how fast the car is
going so some and in some cases most of
the sound is the air passing over the
car and the sound of the wheels turns on
the track on on the track those make
sounds unto themselves
now
are those who live in Los Angeles okay
there's an in and out burger joint
right beside LAX
and it is right there in the approach
for planes landing and you sit there eat
your burger and just watch it happen the
sounds you hear the the the the plane
does not need engines
to come in for a landing it's basically
a glider at that point yeah so if you
want to know yes the engines they're on
and so they're making some sound but
that's not the dominant sound if you
want to know what a pure airplane sounds
like
with air going over the the airfoil it's
what the the plane sound like as it's a
very high pitched sound it's like it's
like Chuck I can't get it
yes yes yes
can you imagine this burger joint right
by LAX the P it's cracked to the rafters
with Aviation nerds
well they better come sponsor a show let
me tell you that
um so so the point is we're talking
about this because of NASCAR All right
so now I've been to a couple of NASCAR
races in my life okay one of them was at
Daytona all right Ryan yeah Florida fla
okay so I was so disappointed you know
why why they have speakers
all around the track
so you don't get the pure sound of the
car moving from your left to your right
the speaker is giving you the sound of
the cars as they are not as they are
Doppler shifted towards you and away
from you wow so you're actually missing
the most beautiful Doppler shift you
could possibly have and it's a 200 mile
an hour car coming towards you and going
away screaming at you that's it
screaming can you imagine how high that
frequency would be yeah at 200 miles an
hour and how low it would be going out
the other side and they got some loud
ass engines on that so you get the
airfoil noise the track noise and the
engine noise but if that if you're in
the crowd if you're in the crowd chat
and you've got these PA speakers around
the track it is literally a constant
wall of sound it's okay that's constant
that's correct so rather and then
therefore they don't lose out on this
sound when the cars are on the far side
of the truck I just think that's that
might be yeah that's probably why they
do it and I've only been to those couple
of tracks so I can't speak for you know
I don't I don't know but so I was so
ready to just feel the Doppler shift and
it wasn't there so so the best way to do
that on the on the televised broadcast
if you if you watch the televised
broadcast of NASCAR
um what you hear from the wide shot when
you're looking at all the cars is
[Music]
yeah yeah it's just it's just a sit home
it's a concert the only time you see the
here the Doppler is it's a single camera
in the ground and the car goes by you
I gotta tell you as much as I make fun
of it sometimes I do like watching it
but not as much as Formula One nope all
right
here and now yep
okay get those racing overalls off here
we go
put that jumpsuit on take those overalls
off right so doppler's traces back to a
German physicist he might have been a
chemist actually a German physicist a
Christian Doppler and he uh he first
measured this did he have a twin did he
have an identical twin no no that was
Einstein with the twin paradox so no I'm
just thinking of doppelganger yeah I was
going to say he was going to Sean
doppelganger
thank you thank you Chuck was there yeah
to tell the jokes on this one
Gary you were not hired to tell jokes
apparently not
so uh so he did it with a with a train a
railroad that's a big thing that's on a
track all right you're doing this before
you had automobiles this was in the
1800s right and so what are you good
you're gonna use a track and it was some
years later where forgive me I forgot
the guy's name who decided to do this
with two orchestras playing on flatbed
rail cars and each Orchestra was told to
play exactly the same note as it's a
subset of an orchestra as the other
Orchestra
Okay so
so they each are playing the same note
and they're coming towards you okay and
so you hear
so the funny part is they as they pass
in front of you you hear the note but
all the notes were higher pitched as
they came towards you and lower pitch as
they went yet you know they're playing
the same note that's what they were
instructed to do so so this was the
people's fascination with this
phenomenon and I mean it was quite the
discovery and by the way we this extends
into the Universe
um we we look at light shifting because
objects moving towards us are away from
us and we can determine exactly oh yeah
so I didn't make it clear doesn't make
sense to you that the amount that the
wave shrinks
with the amount that it expands should
be related to the speed of the object
would you will be together on that
right right so the faster it goes the
higher the pitch or or the lower the
pitch but that each of those would be
more with a higher speed it turns out
there's an exact relationship between
the change in frequency and the speed
and it's the Doppler formula okay so
what happens if I'm if I if I break the
speed of sound oh am I now I head off
steady steady don't get too excited
so in that case the note being played
bursts your eardrums
you you dissolve into a pile of goo all
right so here they are coming towards
you and you have this frequency that is
broadcast and the the moment you because
the Sound Speed is sort of the same in
air except now you're moving through the
air so the next Crest is compressed
relative to the previous one if you keep
increasing your speed
the wavelength gets smaller and smaller
and smaller the frequency gets higher
and higher and higher the pitch gets
higher and higher and higher right there
is a speed with which the next wave
lands exactly on the wave you just
admitted
moments ago
um
when you are doing that you are
traveling the speed of sound and every
one of your waves is on exactly the same
wavefront
so there's a focusing of all of the
sound that came in front of you into one
place
uh and that place is a shock front
moving at the speed of sound
there you go
there you go so what if I what if I
floor it and I go faster than the speed
of sound do I then dismantle the Doppler
okay so the Doppler formula Works
only up to the speed of sound right
after that the free throws it doesn't
make sense to talk about a frequency
because everything is there's no there
is no it's just a cacophony right right
so it's it's what we call the linear
regime of the phenomenon is where the
doc wood formula applies right
wow yeah so so yeah yeah so so I think
because if you can't get it at NASCAR
for the reasons I described then walk up
to the side of any freeway
any freeway and you hear and of course
you can you can tell which of the
electric cars and not because one will
have an engine but they'll all make
sound
every one of them will make sound good
to know next time I'm selling oranges
I'm going to actually try this out oh is
that how you supplement your income from
Starbucks
get out to the major Deegan here in New
York City okay but you know here
humidity Interstate 85 87 87. yeah uh by
the way uh in in New York it's mangoes
uh in La it's oranges okay yeah people
sell mangoes on the freeway here which
is so weird because it's a tropical
fruit and we are nowhere near the
tropics don't worry we will be soon look
that's that's another episode
excellent yes all right so I just want
to throw some Doppler shift out there
all right maybe you knew about it or you
didn't but that's those are the details
and it applies to trains and orchestras
and objects that move throughout I want
to know I want to know who it was put an
orchestra on two flat big cars right was
it was it count loaded
way too much money wait let me get well
I know I know who it is hold on all
right please I'm getting this from a
book
that is coming out this fall it's the
third installment of a start talk book
in a collaboration with National
Geographic very nice book it's a book
it's all written with one of our senior
producers Lindsay Walker so yeah so CHD
boys ballot
interesting names conducted a simple yet
brilliant experiment to demonstrate the
Doppler effect to anyone in doubt
by the way the original Doppler effect
was described just a couple of years
earlier 1842. so he positioned one oh
sorry one band of trumpeters
on a train platform and another band of
trumpers or Board of trained to pass
them by and both were instructed to play
the same note at the same time
and so then this whole thing was
observed by all the Curious onlookers so
yeah it's it's a fun thing but by the
way remember I told you the change in
frequency is your speed in the formula
this is what radar guns do with the
police right they Boop you with a radar
gun and they're looking at the change in
frequency of of microwaves that are
reflected off your car
so if your car absorbs all microwaves
the cop will have no signal back to them
and as far as they concerned your car
isn't even what if I cover the whole car
in an aluminum foil oh well aliens will
not be able to read your thoughts
you'll be safe you'll be safe yay who
doesn't want to be safe
so but if what you put there reflects
them back then it works in the favor of
the cops yeah um so so the point is they
can get their most accurate measure of
your speed if they're standing exactly
in the middle of the street as you drive
towards them they have to be directly in
front of you if they come on an angle to
get the correct speed correct yes but
they're not in the middle of the street
they're on the side somewhere or if
they're clever they're on a turn and
right before the turn you are driving
directly towards them but typically
you're on a straightaway okay and so if
they clock you speeding
they were not standing right in front of
you
you were speeding because at any angle
from being directly in front of the car
there's a cosine of diluting of the
speed that they measure
so if if they're at an angle to you and
they clock you going 100 miles an hour
you're probably going 115 miles an hour
but you still get the ticket
because they didn't measure that that's
the point see and that that's why I have
a problem with uh you know them doing
that to the black NASCAR drivers as they
go around the track so I'm like why are
you shooting him
when I get a ticket
that's only the only NASCAR driver to
ever get a speeding ticket lights and
Sirens
Chuck is an active imagination here
so so all I'm saying so that's so by the
way there's a there's a whole other
uh in principle there's a way to thwart
that that invokes laws of physics that
relate to your car but that's that's for
another day okay and plus I don't think
I should be giving instructions on how
to break the law
okay why
I think a lot of people a lot of people
listening right now have Chuck's
question on the tip of their tongue wow
yeah I'm confused
like you probably listen you'd probably
be the only person I would take advice
from on how to break the law because
everybody else I know is too damn stupid
what it comes down to is at any moment
no matter how fast you're going
there is a part of the car that's not
going forward at all
oh
okay maybe I should save that for
another you damn sure because that is
insane oh okay okay that's a teaser I'm
Gonna Leave it I'm gonna dangle that in
front of him okay all right and on and
Depend and for some trains no matter
their speed there's a part of them
that's moving backwards while they're
going forwards so are you just messing
with us now okay it's true
yeah and I believe for that car you have
to have a flux capacity
wow well there you have it guys an
explainer for StarTalk sports edition
Chuck Gary always good to have you there
always a pleasure pleasure all right
Neil deGrasse Tyson here as well
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]